a woman is accused of killing her mother
in the southwest Valley this morning
Metro Police confirmed that she was
caught a short time later in California
this is not her first run-in with police
before heading to breaking news Ryan
Matthey took a closer look at her police
record
caution tape still up over 12 hours
later and like you know I've been
trick-or-treating here neighbors waking
up around 2 30 a.m police finding a
deceased 68-year-old woman covered in
lacerations and blood but they didn't
find her daughter 28 year old hen
bustami who they say first called in the
death before abruptly hanging up you see
10 o'clock or later we would they would
just be screaming in the backyard or
they'd be fighting and Andres Moreno who
lives nearby says the house in question
was the loudest on the Block I could
always hear the screaming and yelling so
I just try to keep to myself and of
course shortly after you know the
screaming their police presence would be
involved and things were getting on
we'll get settled down and then a week
later it happened again police records
showing officers were called there 12
times just this year mostly for family
disturbances bustami additionally was
arrested at Harry Reid airport in August
after skipping out on her restaurant
check sleeping in front of TSA
threatening to spit on officers and
claiming she was being arrested for
being being too pretty unusual
interactions neighbors say we're all too
common she would come outside and
literally spin in her driveway singing
songs or talking to herself in her
driveway or she just walk up and down
the street muttering to herself I mean
believe she had mental health issues and
she really did desperately need help but
maybe she chose not to get it or you
know who am I to say but there's
obviously something going on with her
was Tommy was apprehended in Barstow
California just a few hours after her
mother died she's set to appear in court
tomorrow for the airport incident but
it's still unclear if she'll be there